why
are dolphins and whales seemingly
actually altruistic
such as swimming around humans in the
presence of sharks is there an
evolutionary element
there's always an evolutionary element i
am simply going to make the phylogenetic
comment which otherwise you would make
and then i'm going to let you
pick up the altruism question um which
is that dolphins are whales
um so saying dolphins and whales is is
fine
um but it's like saying humans and
monkeys or humans and
mammals uh we it is true that we are a
distinct piece of that group
um but just like dolphins um evolved
from whales and are therefore still part
of their original group
um so so it is true for us and primates
and mammals and vertebrates and all
these things but if you say
whales including dolphins then people
like us will know that you're in on the
the phylogenetic reality of the thing um
and it doesn't
really matter that much for most
questions no it does it does because
if you if you just simply sign up for
the phylogenetic interpretation of this
stuff
and you say um you know whales including
dolphins that's one level of
insight that you get just from simply
having understood that that is a
nested set but then you can say stuff
like
dolphins including orcas right and the
point is each of these things tells you
something really
cool about the evolution of these
creatures so anyway what was the
question though about altruism why do
are they do they seem to be altruistic
like when they swim around humans in the
presence of sharks
are they what's going on yeah well first
of all you're talking about some
among the toothed whales which is i
think what you're talking about you're
talking about
highly intelligent creatures who have
certainly noticed
that we humans seem to control a good
deal
of um stuff surrounding their well-being
so it is possible
so let's just just as long as we're on
phylogenetically you said tooth so that
basically you've got bailing whales
whales is a good group that evolves from
um hippos
hippos i'm trying to think about what's
the what's the big
group called uh i can't think of what
the including group in latin is called
anyway something cetacean
oh uh uh said ardiodactyl said
ardiodactyls yes um
so um having gone back into the ocean
you've now got whales and they're
grouped into baleen and toothed whales
and the tooth whales are basically
all those things that we know of as
dolphins including orcas and then
there's one
one big-bodied whale that's toothed oh
uh sperm whale sperm whale yeah and
everything else is bailing whale and
they're um they don't tend to engage in
this sort of thing so you're
probably pretty much talking about tooth
whales and maybe not even all toothed
whales
yeah first of all there's a whole group
of tooth whales that are um
bizarre and little known because they're
pelagic
oh it's bigger than what i just said
then it includes more than the
i believe beaked whales is a subclade
of toothed whales sperm whales is a
subclade of
uh of toothed whales dolphins
um what else anything else in there
dolphins and porpoises
i believe together inside of tooth
whales
in any case so there's a question about
whether
it's altruism whether it is
reciprocal altruism in other words does
doing well by humans result in some kind
of benefit sometimes
is it a misplaced adaptation so for
example when
people have been seen to be drowning and
dolphins have come to their rescue it is
possible that is a dolphin
responding to a sense of
a fellow traveler in need
or it could be that it has a reflex
to um to take a
to preserve a drowning member of its pod
by
putting them up to the surface and that
it's misdirected
um my guess is that dolphins are
too smart for it to be an accident yeah
they're not
they're not confused about that not
being a dolphin who's drowning if it's a
person
yeah i mean you know there are lots of
reflexive things that even a smart
creature can get involved in but this
seems awfully complex
yeah so i don't know yeah probably not
altruism but um
uh collaborativism collaborativism a
kind of reciprocal altruism
uh and yeah i mean dolphins are like us
extremely social and long-lived and they
have generational overlap and yes they
live and extend family groups
and they you know they care for members
of their growth but
group both can and not and um the idea
of expanding that sense of
family of group um to
to include someone not even up their
species
is something that you know frankly most
humans couldn't manage
um it seems um but
but maybe many dolphins can and actually
i'm not sure that's even fair what i
just said because
there are a lot of people who may not be
able to see the value in
say preserving wild animals who still
love their dog
yep for instance i would agree with that
i am concerned though you gave a long
list of similarities between us and
dolphins and you did not do
the work of the balancing list of
differences
oh no yes i did not i just go for it do
it
so i studied uh wales for a time in
college
i was in a marine mammals program and i
did learn that they are aquatic that's
one major difference
they are very i didn't even know squeaky
um yeah and they have flippers well
the squeakiness is probably on kind of
all the salt water they probably just
need more grease
nope because freshwater dolphins are
also squeaky
they are yes you've heard this or you've
just read it in a book
um i prefer not to comment
okay all right we've gotten silly
because we've
been in front of a camera for too many
consecutive minutes that's right